nous sommes en ligne avec Caroline de
Camaret notre envoyé spécial à Kiev elle
s'est entretenue avec Charles Michel qui
viendrait affirmer son soutien à
l'adhésion de l'Ukraine à l'Union
européenne quel est le but de cette
réunion
alors vous savez que la journée a
commencé de deuxième journée donc de
présence très très importante de l'Union
européenne acquieve a commencé par la
visite par la présidente du lavander
leggen de d'un bureau de poste en
centre-ville de kievres où on distribue
les fameuses ampoules à basse
consommation 35 millions disponibles
pour essayer d'éclairer l'Ukraine et à
l'initiative de l'Union européenne il y
a beaucoup évidemment d'aide on le
disait et puis pendant ce temps là et
bien Joseph Borel le chef de la
diplomatie visité des démineurs de
l'Union européenne aussi qui officie
alors cette deuxième journée elle
consiste en un sommet européen on l'a
dit et le président Charles Michel à qui
j'ai parlé il y a quelques minutes nous
disait qu'en effet à l'approche de la
d'anniversaire du 24 février il
craignait des des bombardements
renforcés de la Russie et à il était
temps effectivement de redire le soutien
plein et entier de l'Union européenne à
l'Ukraine même si la perspective
d'adhésion qu'il veut voir au bout du
chemin n'est peut-être pas pour tout de
suite alors vous savez que le président
et d'un ski lui réclame que cette
adhésion ou plus exactement l'ouverture
des négociations d'adhésion
interviennent dès septembre prochain
après le fameux rapport de la commission
sur l'état d'invencement de de cette
Ukraine en pleine guerre sur la voie de
l'Union européenne et ça c'est une de
ces demandes pour avoir quelque chose à
annoncé à son peuple qui soit
véritablement
réjouissant pour lui voilà et
effectivement les Européens et bien en
tout cas ils font ici la démonstration
que ils sont dans la famille européenne
les
Ukrainiens convient leur rendre visite
en très grand nombre
il y aura des conférences de presse
toute la journée sur les télés on voit
des européens depuis hier non-stop pour
des grands grands séminaires et
aujourd'hui on conclura en fait cette
journée en disant que le cercle il y a
un soutien militaire il y a soutien des
sanctions vis-à-vis de la Russie que
tous les leaders européens nous ont dit
fonctionner la Russie pour eux est en
effondrement et puis il y a aussi
évidemment le soutien économique et là
il est majeur vous le disiez supérieur à
celui de la